when she walked into the room it was
obvious that she was going to be the one
she just had something about her the way
she played the scene the kid is very
difficult to deliver the dialogue with
already some very strong decisions you
know like a strong intention and she had
that I saw the wheels turning in her
head and
a script called for another type of girl
it was more of a blonde you know blue I
different and most of the gold who were
seeing were that type of girl but when
she came in she was Burnett we just had
to basically accept it and then find the
look you know that was something that we
did with a you know coffee designer and
myself and auto test you know just to
find the right look what's next week
what's funny way you play another movie
with joel silver is called unknown white
male and it's a thriller thriller action
happening berlin and we're going to
shoot that in january it's basically the
story about a guy was an accident and
wakes up from a coma realized that he's
been replaced by another guy so it's
pretty good it's a good script and
what's that going to come back that's
gonna come out 2011